Immanuel Kant
there's some people who would disagree
with that but he would certainly be on
anybody's list of top three I think he's
the greatest moral philosopher of all
time for a variety of reasons but mostly
because I think he gets the point about
idealism right he gets that both and I
for how the world is and an eye for how
the world should be our perspectives
that have equal value and I think that's
just a bottom line deep insight it's a
simple insight once you've had it you
say gosh how did somebody miss it but in
fact everyone with the exception of
Hannah Arendt who learned that from
Kant's mostly everybody goes in
overboard in one direction or the other
I think Kant made some serious mistakes
and moral philosophy but for that
insight alone he's the greatest moral
philosopher who lived Plato and
Aristotle come in and as you know good
serious seconds in my book and in
anybody's book and Nietzsche I believe
offers a radical deep and problematic
alternative to count in the modern era I
think he is the one philosopher who
deeply questioned moral philosophy but I
think
you